is this video a joke this has got to be
a joke
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by oatsum and
we will be reviewing
husband and wife duo derek huff and
haley erbert's
what i eat in a day but first let me
talk about my sponsor
otsum so as you guys know i'm not vegan
and i'm not dairy free
but i almost exclusively always have
non-dairy milk in my morning lattes and
cereal
and i'm always experimenting with new
ones to switch it up
so i recently tried this new oatsum and
i gotta tell you
i am totally hooked it's
super creamy and rich and they have a
barista blend variety that frosts up
really really nice in my lattes but i
like it because it's made with whole
grain oats
and it's completely plant-based
dairy-free gluten-free
and nut-free so it's a good option for
those with intolerances
and allergies it's also a more
sustainable choice than a lot of other
non-dairy milks out there because it
requires 80
less water to grow than almonds they
also have a chocolate variety which i've
been putting in my smoothies and cereal
to really take breakfast up a notch so
if you want to give this oatsum a try
you can check out the video description
for the link but before we get into this
feel free to pause the screen or look at
my description for a quick disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with previous
or current disordered eating tendencies
that there will be a lot of explicit
diet talk in this review so feel free to
skip this video if it doesn't feel
supportive to your journey
also a quick reminder to ring that
little bell and subscribe so that you
never miss out on an episode alrighty
folks let's do this
we eat this routinely it is very true so
much so that sometimes it gets extremely
boring
but it's healthy and it's good for you
yeah
yeah it's boring i hate it i have to
choke it down but
it's healthy so we persevere i get that
everyone's goals are different
but folks healthy eating shouldn't have
to be boring
actually feeling bored in your healthy
eating routine
is probably the best way to burn out and
just like
throw in the towel i also have to note
that eating the same thing every single
day
isn't exactly the healthiest option
either
i get that if we're short on time or
mental energy having a few
go-to staples definitely gives us more
bandwidth and breathing room
to focus on other things in our lives
but even if the base dish
is the same for you know simplicity's
sake we can still switch up the
ingredients
to ensure that we're getting a wider
range of nutrients in our day
so for example maybe a chicken stir-fry
can become like a tofu stir-fry
and peanut butter toast could become
avocado toast etc
okay so we start out with lemon water
it's a little bit of like
warm lemon water to revitalize and just
energize our
bodies of course you do oh god
does nobody watch my channel i feel like
i'm taking crazy pills
revitalize energize hypnotize
and mesmerize it helps with hydration
too
so we're always getting hydrated i mean
hydrating yes but
so is regular water drink this first
thing in the morning get your gets
everything going get something moving
and then don't eat anything for the next
for 15 minutes
so let everything kind of sink in absorb
your body rock and roll
alkaline energized because the lemon
even though it's acidic when it goes in
your body it turns
alkaline do your job abby
just do your
job all right
so although studies have shown that
lemon juice
may make the ph of our urine more
alkaline
that this does not have any effect on
the ph
of our blood in fact no food has an
effect on our blood ph
because if it did we wouldn't have any
wellness influencers on instagram
because they would all be dead so dark
next whoa what's this so check this out
so 15 minutes after you drink your warm
lemon water
so we do we bust out the celery this um
helps flush out toxins from your liver
oh
god another one another one
well folks get out your wellness
[ __ ] bingo cards because it looks
like it's gonna fill up
quick no no
no okay celery juice is a great way to
get your water in
if you like the taste of celery so
much that you feel like an entire cup
of that burden flavor is your definition
of a good time
but this idea that it helps to flush
toxins out of your liver
has just got to go the guy who made this
up
actually is a psychic not an actual
doctor
and his theory is that celery contains
these
undissolved cluster salts which
apparently bind to toxins
to flush them out but if you ask someone
who actually spends their day consulting
i don't know like research and science
rather than spirit further medical
recommendations you'll know
that nothing about this makes any sense
bile salts have nothing to do with
celery or cluster salts
and there's absolutely nothing magical
about celery
above any other veg this is what happens
when we use a lot of complicated
scary medicalized words put them
together in a sentence that sounds
eloquent
and convince people to just buy into
something
rather than understanding it in full
shut up and take my money
so drink celery juice if you like the
taste
but not to flush anything toxic out
just do it honestly this is the way i
think about it and by the way we're so
la we're doing acceleration so the trend
right now it's like you're drinking like
life changing let's
celebrate wow this guy is what i call
extra and it's also currently making me
really dislike l.a
wild blueberries bananas we have orange
juice we have cilantro then we have
barley grass powder blue spirulina and
atlantic salts made by medical medium to
pull out the heavy metals toxins really
heavy metals
being pulled out of my system as we
speak oh my gosh
people actually follow this guy's advice
and they talk about it publicly like
my mind is actually blown
all right well if you watched my goop
takedown video right here
you might remember that i specifically
reviewed this goopy
wu cocktail already not only is it
so elite exclusive and inaccessible for
most people to be making every single
morning
but it honestly sounds pretty gross
so yes medical medium is right that we
don't want a buildup of heavy metals
going on in our bodies
but what he left out is that anybody
detailed that
you would have to be exposed to a heavy
metal
in exorbitant amounts over a really long
period of time
something that would not likely occur
under
normal living conditions i don't know
most of us don't hop box ourselves in a
sauna with drying paint
now the only scientific explanation that
i could come up with for this guy's
ingredients of choice here is that we do
know that dietary fiber
like the insoluble variety found in wild
blueberries can aid in
heavy metal chelation and cilantro
and spirulina does have some animal
research on it as well for the same
purpose
but the one human study that i did find
found that cilantro
was actually no more effective than a
placebo
in increasing heavy metal excretion so
bottom line no need to waste expensive
wild blueberries in some
seaweed and cilantro flavored smoothie
that just to me
sounds plain wrong next up we have
avocado toast
this is my favorite seasoning it's
everything but the bagel seasoning
so this is mine here a little bit of
drizzle there
and i eat it like that is this a joke
this is a joke right please please for
the love of all that is holy
do not ruin everything bagel avocado
toast for me
ugh i'm gonna have to stop eating it now
because i feel way too douchey having
the same breakfast
these two ate after having like a metal
detox smoothie and celery juice and
lemon water so thank you for ruining
something
that i loved how dare you well nutrition
wise i mean
we could use a little bit of protein
here especially since the three drinks
that preceded this were
also pretty low in protein so you could
puree some
white beans into the avocado which is
actually one of my favorite hacks
or you could throw like a boiled egg on
top but let's see what they're having
for lunch next we have mason jar salad
we get the chicken
pop it in put chickpeas in there
tomatoes there it is cucumbers sprout in
there
carrots in there wax lit is good and
there you have it you got a whole
lunch all right so this is actually a
pretty solid meal
so we've got lots of protein in the
chicken and the chickpeas
we've got fiber rich veggies and we got
some fat
in the dressing yes they could add a
carb into the mix
but because they got a lot of carbs in
their breakfast
and their drinks i would say that this
balances everything out
pretty well but it's food it's nutrition
it's fuel listen this is your body this
is your one vehicle this is it this is
not a rental this is box sold this is
it take care of it a lot of people think
that there are two types of people in
this world
people who eat for pleasure and people
like this who eat
for fuel i actually think the best place
to be
is somewhere in the middle and that's
really what gentle nutrition is all
about
it's not about being militant and only
eating foods that are
clean even if it makes you a hell aboard
and it's not about just eating whatever
tastes good to your palate in that
moment
even if you know it will make you feel
like [ __ ] afterwards
it's actually about choosing the foods
that feel good to you
as an act of self-care but making sure
that the experience
is still emotionally satisfying as well
we
have dinner chickens steamed chicken
broccoli we baked the broccoli today
sweet potatoes delicious we're very
clean but then of course the array of
hot sauce
put it on there like that
who steams chicken breasts this feels
like one of those
terrible celebrity diets that you read
about in a trashy gossip magazine where
the editors literally just reuse the
same
five stock photos for every single
addition like no wonder these two said
that they were bored
sure a meal like this is definitely
healthy and clean
and well balanced like we've got protein
veggies
carbs great but we can
definitely up the satisfaction and
pleasure factor
adding a more complex or interesting
sauce that's not just
hot like maybe chimichurri or pesto
would definitely take this from fitness
competition flavor free fuel
to a more chef-worthy meal and would
also add a source of fat to a dinner
that is
pretty low-fat probably afterwards we
might have a nice little uh
snack like chips and salsa or popcorn or
red vines or twizzlers or
sour patch watermelon something terrible
yes
and this is why eating clean all day
often backfires no you know what i've
been good i deserve this
i mean you can see just in this one
comment that the duo's relationship with
food is
probably a little strange so dragging
yourself through
celery juice and steamed chicken breast
all day
is usually a set up for an overwhelming
desire to eat red vines and chips
and other terrible foods as they say
when you're tired at the end of the day
and ultimately your willpower starts to
run dry
rather had they allowed themselves some
variety
and flavor and pleasure in their daily
meal routine
they might not need to pine over the red
vines like this
they wouldn't feel the need to label
these foods as terrible
because they wouldn't feel so deprived
so
what can we say about derrick and
haley's diet well
you know it says a lot when derek
himself calls his diet out
for being boring and yeah i agree
it is it looks like these two blindly
signed up for goop's weekly newsletter
and made their grocery list based on the
top 10 hits on google for
clean eats i know i'm being a little
salty but it's because i actually
loved derrick on dancing with the stars
and i've actually worked with him on tv
before
so i had to do this segment where i had
to do this line dance
improv style and he didn't even judge me
for my really bad pathetic
moves so honestly the guy seems super
nice
but man we do not need any more [ __ ]
messengers for that medical medium guy
so
for that i am feeling a little let down
everything here
is healthy i cannot critique them on
that but there's so much
pseudoscience and moralizing of food
going on
ugh i just can't
also based on my crude calculations this
is nowhere near enough calories for a
competitive dancer like derek
we're looking at like 1500 calories here
which
is not even enough for his beautiful
wife if she were to be doing pretty much
no activity never mind a very active
young man
so i would love to see some more bulk to
his meals
or a few extra snacks in there to just
help him meet his high
nutrient needs there is more than enough
caloric room for some flavorful sauces
marinades or fun foods which would make
sticking to
both of their wellness and performance
goals a lot easier in the long run
and on that note that is all that i have
for you guys today
i hope you enjoyed this video if you did
be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
with who you want to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
you